are we in entanglement territory are we
jada and willingness situations
oh my gosh well you know i related to
that
a little more than i'd like to admit
first off how are you i'm great
dean just went down for a nap so i'm
having some mommy time so i'm very good
i've gotten much more comfortable in
this motherhood role
because when we first started filming it
was all pretty new to me looking back
i i'm just really proud of myself
because
i didn't really know what i was capable
of i didn't really understand
just how much i could continue to grow
and learn on the most recent episode we
saw
i would imagine your first fight about
motherhood
with another mother with wendy i don't
have sympathy
for her saying she's a new mother i know
i just don't
for your sympathies mind your business
i thought like this is going to be a
great trip and then when wendy just lost
her top
i was flabbergasted
and it wasn't once it was twice
correct no i don't no i don't think that
this warrants an apology
i don't that's why you don't have a lot
of female friends because this is no i
don't have a lot of female friends
because i don't deal with fake [ __ ]
like you that's not good
that's what makes her apology a little
bit um
harder to accept just because she didn't
let it go in the moment and even now she
has to talk about it online so
you know i do accept the apology and
what i hope that people in general learn
is that we just have to be more
supportive of each other
to just be more considerate of what
another person is going through and i
hope wendy learned her lesson too
this is your first season as a mom
right and i know motherhood changes
everything
but how did it change housewife life
because i think i read that
you thought i can't do this i can't be a
mom and
be a part of this show anymore only
because of the timing
i was two months postpartum when we
started filming the show
so i just didn't think i was ready i
didn't think that i would be
able to be fully present with my friends
and the women really rallied together to
help me feel
more comfortable and for them to come
together
and put their differences aside which we
know there are many to put all those
aside and to be there for me
it it reminded me that i do belong in
this group
so it was really the women who helped
convince you it was possible to do both
and to manage both yes it was definitely
the latest think back
five years would you ever think that
this group of women that you walked into
barely knowing anybody would become this
circle that would lift you up in this
way
oh my gosh talk about a revelation i
mean
when people say never say never it is
the most accurate saying
because i never thought that
karen and i would have bonded the way
that we did or
you know even that robin and i would be
as close as we are but
yes this journey has not only been mine
but i've had
quite a few passengers with me and
they've been
really supportive you have already in
the five episodes we've seen
shared so much about your journey and
your struggles
what have you learned about sharing so
much it's actually been a really
positive
response a lot of women especially you
know i talked about having to get a
botox shot in my nether regions
um i do have a tear in my anus
my actual anus i had never before asked
someone in an interview but like
how our thing how's the tear actually
where are we at
yes everything is good um the body goes
through a lot of trauma
after you have a baby and uh that was
just one of the
many traumas and i can say that i'm i'm
recovered i want to take it back a
little
to the serious note um because in
sharing on tv you even shared that you
had thoughts of
suicide in your postpartum journey how
how did you overcome those
well it was really shocking to actually
understand
and acknowledge that i was going through
that in the first place and i didn't
really
anticipate that this would be a journey
that i would go down that i would even
begin to have those types of thoughts
but with the help of a counselor
and uh talking to somebody who can help
me
come to terms with what i'm feeling and
to help me see a different perspective
i was really able to see a brighter side
and i hope that i can just be a voice
for it and encourage anyone who's
experiencing it to get help and if they
can't afford help
that hopefully there are some resources
for them
i think you're going to help a lot of
people by being so open and honest about
it because i think it is one of those
things where we don't talk about it but
until we talk about it
it does uh it doesn't normalize it
doesn't make it a thing that we feel
comfortable talking about
yes yes all right those are all the new
experiences
but there is kind of a deja vu hanging
over this season ashley
yes i know bryce i know yes
the michael stuff your girl baby daddy
was out last night
he was in there with several strippers
what what
he has a boyfriend and a wife what
who's baby daddy
there hasn't been a season of this show
where your marriage isn't called into
question where
your personal life isn't up for
discussion
what can you tell me about what we're
gonna see this season which i think
kicks off in the next episode really
yes it does um
i michael and i are
an unconventional couple in many ways
and
we have more hurdles to overcome
than in my opinion other marriages
when people say that becoming parents
can really change a relationship dynamic
i never thought that would be me and so
it's really just another way that we
have to
strengthen our relationship some
new allegations are brought up by
candace or
make their way to candace what are we
going to see in terms of
how you handled getting this news
candace has said a lot of things that
weren't true
so i didn't you know i took it with a
grain of salt
um and you know it's i
yeah then it then it unfolds and boy
does it unfold i mean there's like
layers upon layers upon layers of it
that unfolds
well somewhere in this unfolding these
layers we see you and michael have a
conversation about
the state of things about it seems these
rumors these allegations
we ended up going back to a hotel
and that feels different to you this
time we're going to see you confront it
head-on with him
i am i'm truthful
and i know that that can be a hard thing
to believe
and that people want to think that we
make up things and that there's all this
these facades around our relationship
but i really am truthful the things that
are true i will talk about them
and if they're true they're true you've
admitted that michael made a mistake
here to we'll figure out how big of a
mistake i guess and what the mistake was
but he made a mistake
yes okay are we going to learn new
things about your
marriage and how it works because of
these conversations
i shared a lot about my marriage in the
past with the ladies
and um the things that i talk about
really shouldn't be a surprise because
they all know me
they all know i'm not a conventional
person and
it's i just don't think it's gonna come
as a shock to anybody
okay i'm picking up on certain words
you're using unconventional conventional
that
needs some room for interpretation here
ashley i mean
are we in entanglement territory are we
jada and willingness situations
oh my gosh you and i
decided we were gonna take our space and
what happened
yeah and then i got into an entanglement
with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes well you know i related to that
a little more than i'd like to admit um
yeah i was like man jada i'm with you
girl i get it i mean marriage is just so
hard and it's really hard being a public
figure and having difficulties and
it's even more difficult when you decide
to talk about them
and say some things that aren't
necessarily fitting the mold of what
people think a marriage is or should be
you and michael obviously you're still
together your things are in a good place
it seems now
oh my gosh i love my husband he's a
great father he's a great husband
and my relationship is going to
withstand
it's strong enough to withstand a lot
and i'm sure there'll be some very
strong reactions to what they see and
what happens
but ultimately the only person who
really lays next to michael at night and
has to have these discussions is me so
why does google call him your ex-husband
oh my gosh google is so
shady okay they have his uh age wrong
okay and let me tell you google would
not put my picture up for the longest
time
so google and i we have a little uh
tension
okay so i don't care all right
the other thing hanging over this season
obviously is
the big altercation the fight which
you were not there to see you were in
the bathroom right
yes yes yes oh my gosh
but yes that's true so you come out of
the bathroom and you walk
into what mayhem
in the purest sense of the word i almost
ran out of the bathroom with my pants
and my ankles because
i so the way that the room was shaking i
thought someone was attacking us
so i i'm first like oh my gosh like i
gotta get out
and then when i came out i saw you know
i a melee i don't really know what i saw
still
i really don't it feels like the
audience
is already on teams has chosen sides
team candace team monique should the
audience be taking sides
i don't think it's about taking sides as
much as it's about
um seeing what happened
and just really trying to understand
that
these women were friends and like this
is not ufc it's not tyson versus
holyfield
you know it's it's two women who just it
got out of hand
right and obviously that altercation is
going to not only change the course of
this season but probably the course of
where potomac
goes season six and beyond what do you
think that looks like how does this
shake things up
i personally have no clue
what the fate is of our
dynamic of our group i mean you know
candace is saying she doesn't want to be
around monique and monique saying
around candace and i'm like well what
does that mean for the rest for all of
us
you know we're just a nice dysfunctional
family you can't have people leaving the
family
you know i will say that there has
definitely been some strategic
word usage and placement of interviews
and
things like that that i personally have
never
thought to to operate that way but um
you know it's just a different this is a
whole different
animal who are you calling out there are
you saying candace monique somebody else
well no i mean i saw that you know
candace did an instagram live where she
said all this stuff and all these press
outlets picked it up
and monique is talking about it they're
two people who can
you know they are handling it the way
that they want just different than what
i would have done
all right we have a lot of season left
to watch so outside of
your personal struggles the altercation
what are you excited for the fans to
experience the rest of this season
that's a lot eh yeah um
[Music]
i am really excited for
everyone to just see how our group
continues to change and continues to
evolve nothing is stagnant nothing just
stays the way it is we all continue to
grow
and evolve and sometimes for the best
and you know sometimes for the worst but
either way we're always in motion well
that's why you're the best housewives
franchise on tv
i always say that now one time with a
people in the back yes thank you thank
you
yes thank you all right my last question
the confessional wig from season four
where is it yes
where does it look first of all i loved
that wig
thank you okay i it was not quite my
vision
but it was still you know it did its job
anyways all right bryce i feel your
shade so
um the wig i actually gave it to my mom
who wore it to my baby shower and
the resemblance between us was
ridiculous
giselle actually recognized it first and
she was like
ashley that's your wig and yes it was my
wig
so we looked like twins i will say the
wig looks better
in your instagram than it did in the
confessional oh that's nice that's nice
also i mean to be fair i was like so
bloated and
goodness knows what else was working
against that wig you know in terms of
fluid and all types of craziness
the last thing you wanted to do was sit
down under hot lights with a microphone
and be interrogated about your life
oh my gosh yes i mean i was super
pregnant and that's even why i wore the
wig because i didn't want anyone
touching my hair
so i was like just put a wig on this
thing so that's how it came about
now it's part of housewives history so
it's a little infamous but you know what
i still love it
[Music]
okay
you